a small agency owner asked me hey man i
think i've saturated my niche i don't
think i can run any more ads to reach
more people and i said okay well how
many pieces of creative are you putting
out a week and he's like oh dude we've
got that covered we're putting out seven
pieces a week of new ad creative he was
so proud of that and it was great
because this public call and i was like
do you want to know how many pieces of
ad creative just one of my companies
puts out he was like how many and i was
like we're putting out 30 every two days
and he just stood there silently and so
a lot of times people see these people
who are way up on the mountain and they
think oh like they're doing something
fancier than me they've got this thing
they're just doing more total volume of
work than you are and they've created
the system of doing more of that
advanced is not doing the fancy stuff
it's doing more of the basics and doing
them at scale that is what gets you to
climb the mountain that you're looking
for financially it's not doing some
magic pill that's going to knock you out
of the park